[Música]
2021 decir que el año no empezó bien es
quedarse corto el kobe 19 está
paralizando entre otras cosas el sistema
global de la moda las medidas sanitarias
impiden que las semanas de la moda se
celebren en todos los continentes lo que
significa básicamente que no hay
espectáculos ni eventos es la depresión
no porque la moda consiste en adaptarse
la pandemia trastocó todos se combinan
donde llegó de golpe nadie se lo
esperaba no ver un desfile de moda no
vestirse no besarse la moda se vive se
ve y se toca vamos a hacer que sea
divertido sentarse en nuestro sofá a ver
un desfile de moda
los fashion films lo digital siempre ha
sido una herramienta que debe
incorporarse a lo que existe todas las
marcas se comunicarán a través de estos
fashion films pero es complicado porque
hay que evocar la caída de los
materiales la corrección de los cortes
la coherencia de los colores y exaltar
el sentido del tacto para lograr estos
objetivos yo recurrió el director
italiano matteo garrone y
creo que es muy buen director para el
cine así como para la alta costura
su enfoque es tan artístico como
artesanal y quema toboso artesanal y
creo que es muy importante porque la
costura no hay que olvidarlo es
artesanal
aunque no desfile la alta costura sigue
siendo un laboratorio que sabe manejar
las impresoras 3d como los símbolos
[Música]
cuando miramos nuestro planeta desde
lejos nos damos cuenta de lo fértil que
es comprendemos su singularidad es un
organismo único en el que todo está
interconectado
su imán ha casado ha desarrollado una
costura sin costuras anidados unos
dentro de otros los elementos son el
resultado de una tecnología de
vanguardia que desarrolló a partir de
proteínas elaboradas
las proteínas elaboradas se contraen al
sumergirse en el agua se mueven y dan
nuevas formas entonces descubrimos que
es posible controlar estas formas con la
impresión digital
para vestir sus modelos ruymán a casa to
aboga por la inclusión de bellezas
diferentes
lauren va a ser era una modelo de moda
convertida en activista tras perder las
dos piernas por el síndrome de shock
tóxico causado por un tampón
tuve dos piernas y luego teniendo las
que tengo ahora puedo decir que la
tecnología ha jugado un papel importante
en la mujer en la que me he convertido
poder moverme como lo hago correr como
lo hago realmente siento que todos vamos
a necesitar la tecnología para avanzar
para ser mejores en el futuro yo solo me
adelante
así soy el futuro la inclusión la
diversidad en 2021 algunos tabúes
desaparecieron en la semana de la moda
de lomé togo de fofó balazo de 34 años
adoptó el nombre artístico alexandra
magix él es una empresaria togolesa
modelo motociclista andrógina
tengo la impresión de que los andrógenos
son bastante raros y la verdad es que no
encontré ninguna a menudo encuentro
chicas masculinas pero no realmente
andrógenos que tienen características
tanto masculinas como femeninas
por culpa de la sociedad cuando eres
mujer tienes que llevar vestidos tiene
que ser femenina y todo eso pero excepto
ambos lados en mis sesiones es más
masculino porque es más divertido para
mí y me encanta el estilo masculino así
que juego con él
en todo como en muchas partes del mundo
hay un creciente interés con el
reciclaje
y estoy convencido de lo repito todo el
día la palanca más importante para el
desarrollo de áfrica que aún se
desconoce son los residuos la moda puede
encontrar aquí material ya sea en
plástico textil o papel para sublimar a
las mujeres para sublimar a los hombres
simplemente y eso gracias a los residuos
es fabuloso no ifo cambian con a ver a
mí todavía tenemos que gestionar mejor
estos residuos nada se crea nada se
pierde todo se transforma para
el reciclaje ahora se enseña en la
escuela el prestigioso instituto francés
de la moda de parís ha abierto una
cátedra para esto patrocinada por el
grupo care inc winston si estamos en
movimiento eso es seguro y se acelerará
estamos seguros que formará la próxima
generación tiene un enorme potencial de
acción y eso es lo que queremos lograr
en otoño las medidas sanitarias se
hicieron menos restrictivas y se
reanudaron los desfiles con mensajes
contundentes
dejemos de hablar del calentamiento
global pasemos a la acción lo entiende
dejemos de destruir pensemos con el
corazón salvar el planeta significa
salvar el mundo en el que vivimos una
tierra que deberíamos poder recorrer en
todas las direcciones sin obstáculos sin
peligro para el verano 2022 dior se
inspiran las revoluciones feministas de
los años 60 los cuerpos son libres y los
tacones son planos
esto es obviamente algo bueno esto es
algo que debería haber ocurrido hace
mucho tiempo en la moda
y me encanta que maría gracias nos
acompañe con zapatos planos
es más fácil cuando uno quiere escapar
dejar la realidad otro gran principio de
la moda por los cuentos de hadas como el
delirio aquí no tom brown quien pone en
escenario a lindsey vonn campeona
olímpica de esquí estadounidense nos
lleva a un maravilloso cuento de
invierno que casi nos hace creer en papá
noel
[Música]